what is up everybody its Anna Mac and
welcome to another episode of the week's
best anime videos which is a weekly
newscast on our channel all the links
are in the description recommendations
go in the comments the number one huge
piece of news for this week is that
tomorrow is the big day tomorrow at 4
p.m. Eastern Standard Time on the black
Critic guys Channel the epic REM vs.
Amelia best girl showdown is going down
alive this is going to be an epic live
anime debate about who is best girl and
our easy row REM or Amelia on the REM
team will have black criticai and anime
recon and on the Amelia team we have
myself Anna Mac along with bricks from
all day anime and mediating the whole
thing to make sure that we don't get out
of line is Mackel not the mustache of
wisdom so definitely you don't want to
miss that today black credit guy
actually released a trailer on his
channel for this epic debate so I will
leave the link in the description be
sure to click it and check it out and be
sure to subscribe to his channel so you
don't miss the big showdown tomorrow and
if you've been wondering how I Anna Mac
the Imperator of anime has been
preparing for this epic battle I will
show you exactly how
[Music]
[Music]
and while we're on the subject of black
credit guy he recently reviewed the
shoto romance
anime maid-sama and while I said that I
would cosplay as a maid at 1 million
subscribers because I know how
unrealistic that is this guy Tony the
black criticai has no problem whatsoever
cosplaying as a maid just for fun huge
respect bro and speaking of maids last
week the first maid gym opened in
Tokyo's Akihabara neighborhood now
basically what this is is a gym where
cute japanese maids help you work out
now I don't know about you guys but I've
always been one of those people that
needs that extra kick that extra
motivation to workout and I think they
might have found a golden formula here
hopefully we're gonna be talking
franchising and expanding big time also
this week a brand new trailer for the
ghost in the shell' live action film
starring Scarlett Johansson has been
released and I have to say it looks
pretty amazing it is clear to me that
the creators of this film are trying to
stay faithful to the original 1990s
animated films and there are also a few
nods to the ghost in the shell' anime
not the biggest nod to the anime in my
opinion is the fact that Scarlett
Johansson is playing multikill we know
that in the anime multikill is quite
attractive and of course Scarlett is a
beautiful woman but if we look at the
1990s original animated films multikill
looks quite different she's actually
very masculine and looks nothing like
Scarlett Johansson this trailer was also
useful because it gave us a lot of hints
about what the actual story the plot
line in the film is going to be from the
looks of it a major plot point is going
to be multi-code trying to remember her
past because from the looks of it the
people that created her that turned her
into a cyborg told her that she didn't
have a family
however the trailer seems to imply that
she was lied to that she actually had a
family and that she was essentially
stolen from her family in order to
become a cyborg at any rate so far the
visuals for this film have been on point
so I'm gonna reserve judgment and see
what happens I think this could be a
really good film or of course they could
mess it up but we'll have to wait and
see cyanide Blizzard uploaded his latest
first impressions video this week and
this time it was for kuzu no han chi or
scums wish believe it or not cyanide and
Draconis actually gave this episode a
pretty good review which is always a
good sign because it was actually after
watching a cyanides first impression of
cage oh that I decided to give that show
a chance and I ended up loving it it was
hilarious most underrated show of 2016
so yeah cyanide thanks for this review
I'm going to check out this show this
past week the Ishta released his latest
piano cover and this time it was of the
opening for season two of blue exorcist
as always this guy is just such a huge
talent so whenever he uploads a new
video I always encourage people to go
and check it out and my favorite a MV
for this week was a guilty crown a MV by
a youtuber called Fitness a mV
this video makes really great use of
sound to accompany the visuals I believe
that the genre of the song used here
would fall into the drum and bass genre
something along those lines which is not
something that I usually listen to but
it really works well in this case I
enjoyed it immensely its creative its
unique definitely check it out and
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
these videos be sure to LIKE and
subscribe and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]